The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
LORENZO ROSASCO: So
what we want to do now
is to move away
from local methods
and start to do some form of
global regularization method.
The word regularization I'm
going to use broadly as a term
to define procedures,
statistical procedures
and computational
procedure that do
have some parameters that
allow to do from complex model
to simple model in
a very broad sense.
What I mean by complex is
something that is potentially
going closer to overfitting and
by simple model something that
is giving me something, which
is stable with respect to data.
So we're going to consider
the following algorithm.
I imagine a lot of you
have seen it before.
This is called-- it has a
bunch of different names--
probably the most famous one
is Tikhonov regularization.
A bunch of people at the
beginning of the '60s
thought about something
similar either in the context
of statistics or solving
linear equations.
So Tikhonov is the only one for
which I can find the picture.
The other one was
Philips, and then there
is Hoerl and other people.
They basically thought all
about this same procedure.
The procedure basically
is based on a functional
that you want to minimize
based on two terms.
So there are several
ingredients going on here.
First of all, this is f of x.
We assume the
functional form of-- we
try to estimate the
function, and we
do assume a parametric form
of this function, which
in this case, just linear.
And for the time being,
because you can really,
you can put it back in, I
don't look at the offset.
So I just take lines
passing through the origin.
And this is just because
you can prove in one line
that you can put back in
the offset at zero cost.
So for the time
being, just think
that data are actually standard.
The way you try to estimate
this parameter is, on one hand,
try to make the empirical error
small, and on the other hand,
you put a budget on the weights.
The reason why you do this--
there are a bunch of
way to explain this.
Andrei yesterday talked about
margin, and different lines,
and so on.
Another way to think about
it is that you can convince
yourself-- and we were
going to see later--
that if you're in low dimension,
a line is a very poor model.
Because basically if you
have more than a few points--
and they're not
standing on the line--
you will not be able
to make zero error.
But if the number
of points is lower
than the number
of dimension, you
can show that the line actually
can give you zero error.
It's just a matter of
degrees of freedom.
You have fewer equations
than the actual variables.
So what you do is
that you actually
add a regularization theorem.
It's basically a theorem that
makes the problem well-posed.
We're going to see
this in a minute
from a different perspective.
The easiest one is
going to be numerical.
We stick to least squares
for-- and there is--
so there is an extra
parenthesis that I forgot,
but before I tell you why
we use least squares also
let me tell you that--
as somebody pointed out--
there is a mistake here,
because this is a minus.
It should just be a minus.
I'll fix this.
So back, why do you
use least squares?
OK, so least squares
on the one hand,
if you're in low
dimension especially,
you can think of least
squares as its way is basic,
but it's not a very robust
way to measure error,
because you squared them.
And so just one error
can count a lot.
So typically, there
is a whole literature
on robust statistics, where
you want to replace least
square with something
like an absolute value
or something like that.
It turns out that at
least in our experience
and when you have high
dimensional problem,
it's not completely clear how
much this kind of instability
will occur and will not
be cured by just adding
some regularization term.
And the computation
underlying this algorithm
are extremely, extremely simple.
So that's why we're
sticking to this, because it
works pretty well in practice.
We actually developed
in the last few years
some toolbox that you can use.
They're pretty
much plug and play.
And because the algorithm
is easy to understand
in simpler terms.
Yesterday, Andrei was
talking about SVM.
SVM is very similar
in principle.
Basically the only
difference is that you change
the way you measure cost here.
This algorithm you can use
both for classification
and regression, whereas SVM--
the one which was
talked about yesterday--
is just for classification.
And because the cost function
turns out to be non-smooth--
and non-smooth is basically
non-differentiable--
and so the whole math is
much more complicated,
because you have to learn
how to minimize things
that are not differentiable.
So in this case, you can
stick to elementary stuff.
And I think I did somewhere,
that also because Legendre
200 years ago said that least
squares are really great.
There is this old story--
who between Gauss and Legendre
invented least squares first.
And there are actually
long articles about this.
But anyway, it's
around that time.
It's around the end of the--
this is when he was
born-- it's around
the end of the 18th century.
So the algorithm is pretty old.
So what's the idea?
So back to the case we
had before, you're going
to take a linear function.
So one thing is--
just to be careful--
think about it once.
Because if you've never
thought about it before,
it's good to focus.
When you do this drawing,
this is not f of x.
This line is not f of x.
It's f of x equals zero.
So I think I made enough
time to have a 3D plot.
So f of x is actually a plane
that cuts through the slide.
It's positive, when
it's not dotted--
because this points are
positive-- and then becomes
negative.
And this line is
where it changes sign.
So the decision boundary
is not f of x itself,
but it's the level
set that corresponds
to f of x equals zero.
Whereas f of x itself
is this one line.
If you think in one
dimension, the points
are just standing on a line.
Some here are plus 1.
Some here are minus 1.
So what is f of x?
It's just a line.
What is the decision
boundary in this case?
It will just be one point
in this case actually,
because it's just
one line that cuts
the input line in one point.
And that's it.
If you were to take a more
complicated nonlinear line,
it would be more than one point.
In two dimension,
it becomes one line.
In three dimension, it becomes
a plane, and so on and so forth.
But the important piece-- just
a remember, at least once--
then we look at this plot.
This is not f of
x, but only the set
f of x equals zero, which
is where you change sign.
And that's how you're
going to make prediction.
You take real valued
functions, so you
would like-- in principle,
in classification, you
would allow this function
just to be binary.
But optimization with binary
functions is very hard.
So what you typically
do to relax this?
You just allow it to be
a real valued function,
and then you take a sign.
When it's positive,
you take plus 1.
If it's negative,
you say minus 1.
If it's a regression
problem, you just
keep it for what it is.
And how many free parameters
has this algorithm?
Well, one.
It's lambda for now and w.
But w we're going to solve
by solving this optimization
problem.
How about lambda?
Well, whatever we
discussed before for k.
We would try to sit
down and do some bias
variance of the composition,
see what it depends on,
try to see if we can
get a grasp on what
the theory of this algorithm is.
And then we try to see if
we can use cross-validation.
You can do all these
things, so we're not
going to discuss much how you
choose lambda, but most of you
are going to discuss how you can
compute the minimizer of this.
And this is not a problem,
because this is smooth.
So you can take the
retrospect to w and also this.
So what you can do is just to
take the derivative of this,
set it equal to zero,
and check what happens.
So it's useful to
do this to other--
just some vectorial notation.
We've already seen it before.
So you take all the x's and you
stack it as rows of the data
matrix x of n.
So this ny, you just stack
them as entries of a vector.
You call it yn.
Then you can rewrite
this term just
in this way, as this vector
minus this vector here, which
you obtain by multiplying
the matrix with w.
So this norm is the norm in Rn.
So this is just
simple rewriting.
It's useful just
because if you now
take the derivative
of this with respect
to w, set it equal to
zero, you get this.
This is the gradient.
So I haven't set it to zero yet.
This is the gradient of
the least square part.
This is the gradient
of the second term.
It is still
multiplied by lambda.
If you set them equal to
zero, what you get is this.
You take everything with x,
so the 2 and the 2 goes away.
You took everything with
x, and you put it here.
There's still the
one here with lambda.
You put it here.
You take this term
in x transpose y,
and you put it on the
other side of the equality.
So you take everything with
w on one side and everything
without w on the other side.
And then here, I remove
n by multiplying.
And so what you get
is a linear system.
It's just a linear system.
So that's the beauty
of least squares.
Whether you
regularize it or not--
in this case for this simple
squared loss regularization,
all you get is a linear system.
And this is the first way
to think about the effect
of adding this term.
So what is this doing?
So just quickly for you a
quick linear system recap.
You're solving a linear system.
I changed notation.
This is just a parenthesis,
just a little bit.
The simplest case
you can think of
is the case where m is diagonal.
Suppose it's just a diagonal
matrix, a square diagonal
matrix.
How do you solve this problem?
You have to invert the matrix m.
What is the inverse
of a diagonal matrix?
So it's just another
diagonal matrix.
On the entries, instead of, say,
sigma, you have 1 over sigma
or whatever it is.
So what you see is that if
m-- you just consider m--
and m is diagonal
like this-- this
is what you're going to get.
Suppose that now
some of these numbers
are actually small, then
when you take 1 over,
this is going to blow up.
When you apply this matrix
to b, what you might have is
that if you change the
sigmas or the b slightly,
you can have an explosion.
And if you want, this is
one way to understand why
adding the lambda would help.
And it's another way to look
at overfitting, if you want,
from a numerical point of view.
You take the data.
You change them slightly, and
you have numerical instability
right away.
What is the effect
of adding this term?
Well, what you see
is that instead
of just doing m minus 1, you're
doing m plus lambda I minus 1.
And this is the simple
case, where it's diagonal.
But what you see is that on
the diagonal instead of 1
over sigma 1, you take 1
over sigma 1 plus lambda.
If sigma 1 is big, adding
this lambda won't matter.
If sigma-- for example, sigma
d, now think there are order.
I'm thinking they are
order, and sigma d is small.
If this is small, at some point
lambda is going to jump in,
make the problem
stable at the price
of ignoring the
information in that sigma,
that you basically
consider it to be
at the same size of the
noise or the perturbation
or the sample in your data.
Does this make sense?
So this is what the
algorithm is doing.
And it's a numerical way
to look at stability.
But you can imagine that this
is an immediate statistical
consequence.
You change the data
slightly, you'll
have a big change in your
solution and the other way
around.
And lambda governs this
by basically telling you
how much this is invertible.
So it's a connection between
statistical and numerical
stability.
Now of course, you can say,
this is oversimplistic,
because this is just
a diagonal matrix.
But basically, if
you now take matrices
that you can diagonalize,
conceptually nothing
would change.
Because basically
you would have that
if you have a matrix-- so
there is a mistake here.
There should be no minus 1.
If you have an m that you can--
this is just sigma, not minus 1.
You can just diagonalize it.
And now every operation you
want to do on the matrix you
can just do on the diagonal.
So all the reasoning
here will work the same.
Only now you have
to remember that you
have to squeeze the diagonal
matrix in between v and v
transpose.
I'm not saying that this is
what you want to do numerically.
But I'm just saying that the
conceptual reasoning here--
that we tell it that this
was the effect of lambda--
is going to hold
just the same here.
This is m, which you can
write like this-- m minus 1
you can write like this.
And so this is just going to
be the same diagonal terms
inverted.
And now you see the
effect of lambda.
It's just the same.
So once you grasp
this conceptually,
for any matrix you can make
diagonal, it's the same.
And the point is
that as long as you
have a symmetric positive
definite matrix, the reason you
can diagonalize it, you just
have the same thing squeezed
in between v and v transpose.
And that's what we have,
because instead of--
because what we have is
exactly this matrix here.
So instead of-- and you see
here that basically this
depends a lot on the
dimensionality of the data.
If the number of points is much
bigger than the dimensionality,
this matrix in
principle could be--
it's easier that is invertible.
But if the number
of points is smaller
than the dimensionality--
how big is this matrix?
So xn is-- you remember
how big was xn?
It was the rows were the
points, and the columns
were the variable.
So how big is this?
And we call this d.
We called the length n.
So this is--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LORENZO ROSASCO: --n by d.
So this matrix here is how big?
Just d by d, and
the number of points
is smaller than the
number dimension.
The rank of this--
this is going to
be rank-deficient.
So it's not invertible.
So if the number of points is
more, if you're in a high--
so called
high-dimensional scenario,
where the number of
points is more than
the number of
dimension, for sure you
won't be able to invert this.
Ordinary least
squares will not work.
It will be unstable.
And then you will
have to regularize
to get anything reasonable.
So in the case of least squares,
just by setting rank to zero
and looking in this computation
to get a grasp of both.
What kind of computation
you have to do,
and what they mean both
from the statistical
and the numerical point of view.
And that's why that's one of
the beauty of least squares.
We could stick to a whole
derivation of this--
so this is more the
linear system perspective.
There is a whole
literature trying
to justify more from a
statistical point of view what
I'm saying.
You can talk about the
maximum likelihood,
then you can talk about
maximum a posteriori.
You can talk about variance
reduction and so-called Stein
effect.
And you can make a much bigger
story trying, for example,
to develop the whole theory of
shrinkage estimators, the bias
variance tradeoff of this.
But we're not going
to talk about that.
So this simple
numerical stability,
statistical stability
intuition is
going to be my main motivation
for considering these schemes.
So let me skip these.
I wanted to show the demo, but--
it's very simple.
It's going to be very
stable, because you're just
drawing a one-dimensional line.
Then you move on just
a bit, because we
didn't cover as much as
I want in the first part.
So first of all, so far so good?
Are you all with me about this?
So again, the basic
thing if you want--
all the interesting--
so this is the one line,
where there is something
conceptual happening.
This is the one line, where we
make it a bit more complicated
mathematically.
And then all you have
to do is to match this
with what we just wrote before.
That's all.
These are the main three
things we want to do.
And think a bit
about dimensionality.
Now if you look at a problem
even like this, as I said,
this might be misleading--
a low dimension.
And in fact, what we
typically do in high dimension
is that, first of all, you
start with the linear model
and you see how far
you can go with that.
And typically, you go a bit
further that you might imagine.
But still, you can
think, why should I just
stick to linear decision rule?
This won't give me
much of a flexibility.
So in this case,
obviously, it looks
like something that
would be better,
some kind of quadric
decision boundary.
So how can you do this?
How can you go--
suppose that I give you
the code of least squares.
And you're the
laziest programmer
in the world, which in
my case is actually not
that hard to imagine.
How can you recycle
the code to fit,
to create a solution
like this, instead
of a solution like this?
You see the question?
I give you the code
to solve this problem,
the one I showed you before--
the linear system for
different lambdas.
But you want to go from this
solution to the solution.
How could you do that?
So one way you can do
it in this simple case
is-- this is the example.
So the idea is--
you remember the matrix?
I'm going to invent new
entries of the matrix,
not of the points, because
you cannot invent points,
but of the variables.
So what you're going to do,
instead of just-- they can say,
in this case I call them x1, x2.
I'm just in two dimension.
These are my data.
This is just another
example of this.
So these are my data--
sorry these are--
let's see what they are.
This is one point.
X1 and x2 here
are just the entry
of the point x, so
the first coordinate
and the second coordinate.
So what you said is
exactly one way to do this.
And it is--
I'm going to now build a
new vector representation
of the same points.
So it's going to
be the same point,
but instead of two
coordinates I now use
three, which are going to be
the first coordinate square,
the second coordinate square,
and the product of the two
coordinates.
Once I've done this, I
forget about how I got this,
and I just treat it
as new variables.
And I take a linear model
with that variables.
It's a linear model with
these new variables,
but it's a new linear model
with the original variables.
And that's what you see here.
So x tilde is this stuff.
It's just a new
vector representation.
And now I'm linear with
respect to this new vector
representation.
But when you write
x tilde explicitly,
it's some kind of
non-linear function
of the original variable.
So this function
here is non-linear
in the original variable.
It's harder to say
than probably to see.
Does it make sense?
So if you do this,
you're completely
recycling the beauty
of the linearity
from a computational
point of view while
augmenting the
power of your model
from linear to non-linear.
It's still parametric in the
sense that in this case--
what I mean by parametric
is that we still
fix a priori the
number of degrees
of freedom of our problem.
It was true now I make it three.
More general I could
make it p, but the number
of numbers I have to
find is fixed a priori.
It doesn't depend on my
data, and it's fixed.
But I can definitely go
from linear to non-linear.
So let's keep on going.
So from the simple linear model
we already went quite far,
because we basically know
that with the same computation
we can now solve
stuff like this.
Let's take a couple
of steps further.
So one is-- appreciate
that really the code
is just the same.
Instead of x, I have
to do a pre-processing
to replace x with this
new matrix x tilde, which
is the one which instead of
being n by d, is now n by p
where p is this new number
of variables that I invented.
Now it's useful to just
get the feeling of what is
the complexity of this method.
And this is a very
quick complexity recap.
Here basically, the
product of two numbers
is going to count one.
And then when you take product
of vectors of matrices,
you just count on any real
number multiplication you do.
And this is a quick recap.
If I multiply two vectors
of size p, the cost p,
matrix vector is going to be np.
Matrix matrix is going
to be n square p.
You have n vectors.
And one-to-one, other n vectors.
And they are size p, so each
time you have-- it costs you p.
And you have to do n against n.
So it's going to be n square p.
And the last one
is-- this is a much--
less clear to just
look at it like this.
But roughly speaking,
the inversion of a matrix
costs roughly speaking n
cube in the worst case.
It's just to give you a feeling
of what the complexity are.
So it makes sense?
It's a bit quick,
but it's simple.
If you know it, OK.
Otherwise, you just
take this on the side,
when you think about this.
So what is the
complexity of this?
Well, the matrix-- you have
to multiply this times this,
and this is going to
cost you nd or np.
You have to build this matrix.
This is going to cost you
n square d or n square p.
And then you have to invert.
These are going to be n cube.
So-- sorry, p cubed,
because with this matrix is
going to be-- or d cube,
because this matrix is d by d.
So this is, roughly
speaking, the cost.
So now look at this.
This is-- I take this.
In this case, p is the
new variable, otherwise d.
So in this case, I have p cube,
and then I have p square n.
But one question is
what if n is much--
and that's a fact-- what if
n is much smaller than p?
If n is a 10, do I
really have to pay
quadratic or even cubic
in the number of dimension
to solve this problem?
Because in some sense, it looks
I'm overshooting things a bit.
Because I'm inverting a
matrix, yes, but this matrix
is really a rank n.
It only has n rows that are
linearly independent at most.
It might be less,
but at most it has n.
So can I break the
complexity of this?
Linear system have
to solve, you just
use the table I
showed you before.
Check the computation.
These are the computation
you have to do.
And one observation
here is you pay really
a lot in the dimension,
the number of variables
or the number of
features you invented.
And this might be OK,
when p is smaller than n.
But one thing-- this
seems wrong intuitively,
when n is much smaller than p.
Because the complexity
of the problem,
the rank of the
problem is just n.
The matrix here has n
rows and d or p columns
depending on which
representation you take.
And so the rank of the
whole thing is at most n,
if n is much smaller.
So now the red dot appears.
And what you can do is
proving this one line.
So let's see what
they do, and then I'll
tell you how you can prove it.
And it's an exercise.
So you see here if
you invert this,
then you have to
multiply x transpose
y times the inverse
of this matrix, which
is what's written in here.
So I claim that this
equality stands.
Look what it does.
I take this x transpose.
I move it in front.
But then if I do
this, you clearly
see that I'm messing
around with dimensions.
So what you do is that you have
to switch the order of the two
matrices in the middle.
Now from a dimensionality
point of view, at least,
I still see that this
matrix and this matrix
have the same dimension.
How do you prove this?
Well, you basically
just need to do SVD.
You take the singular-value
decomposition of the matrix Xn.
You plug it in, and you
just compute things.
And you check that this
side of the equality
is the same of this
side of the equality.
So there's nothing
more than this,
but we're going to skip this.
So you just take this as a fact.
It's a little trick.
Why do I want to do this trick?
Because look, now what I
say is that my w is going
to be x transpose of something.
What is this something?
So w is going to be X
transpose of this thing here.
How big is this vector?
So how big is this
matrix first of all?
So remember, Xn was how big?
AUDIENCE: N by d.
LORENZO ROSASCO: N by d or p.
How big is this?
AUDIENCE: N by n.
LORENZO ROSASCO: N by n.
So how big is this vector?
It's n by 1.
So now I have to--
I found out that
my w can always be
written as x transpose
c, where c is just
an n-dimensional vector.
I rewrote it like
this, if you want.
So what is the
cost of doing this?
Well, this was the
But now you just have to do--
so let's say what is the
cost of doing this thing here
above the bracket?
Well, if this one was
p cube p square n,
this one will be how much?
I have that this
matrix will say p by p,
and then this vector was p by 1.
Whereas here, my matrix is n by
n, and the victory is n by 1.
So you basically have that
these two numbers swap.
Instead of having
this complexity,
now you have a complexity,
which is n cube.
And then you have n square
p, which sounds about right.
It's linear in p.
You cannot avoid that.
You have to look at
the data at least once.
But then it's polynomial only in
the small quantity of the two.
So in some sense,
what you see is
that, depending on the
size of n, of course,
you still have to do
this multiplication.
But this multiplication
is just n, nd, or np.
So let's just recap
what I'm telling you.
This is a lot more
mathematical fact I put.
I have a warning here.
The first thing is the
question should be clear.
Can I break the complexity
of this in the case
when n is smaller than p or d?
This is relevant because the
question came out a second ago,
which was should
I always explode
the dimension of my features?
And here what you see is that--
well, at least for now we
see that even if you do,
you don't pay more
than linearly in that.
And the way you
prove it is A, you
observe this factor,
which, again, I
measured if you're curious,
to show how you do it,
but it's a one line.
And 2, you observe that
once you have this,
if you just rewrite w, you can
write w as a x transpose c.
And to find a c-- which is now
you basically re-parametrize--
and to find the new c
is going to cost you
only n cube n square p.
So you do exactly
what you wanted to do.
And basically,
what you see now is
that whenever you
do least squares,
you can check the
number of dimensions,
the number of points, and always
re-parametrize the problem
in such a way that complexity
is depending linearly
on the bigger of the
two and polynomially
on the smaller of the two.
So that's good news.
Oh, I wrote it.
So this is where
we are right now.
So if we're lost now, you're
going to become completely lost
in one second.
Because this is
what we want to do.
We want to introduce kernel
in the simplest possible way,
which is the following.
So look at-- this
is what we find out.
We discovered, we
actually proved a theorem.
And the theorem
says that the w's
that are output by the least
squares algorithm are not
any possible
d-dimensional vectors,
but they're always
vectors that I
can write as the combination
of the training set vectors.
So xi is long d or p,
and I've summed them up
with these weights.
And the w's that are going
to come out of least squares
are always of that form.
They cannot be of
any other form.
This is called the
representer theorem.
It's the basic theorem of
so-called kernel methods.
It shows you that the
solution you're looking for
can be written as a linear
superposition of these terms.
If you now write--
this is just the w.
Let's just write down f of x.
F of x is going to be
x transpose w, just
the linear function.
And now you can-- if you write
it down, you just get this.
By linearity you can--
so w is written like this.
You multiply by x transpose.
This is a finite sum.
So you can let x
transpose inside the sum.
This is what you get.
Are you OK?
So you have x
transpose times a sum.
This is the sum of x transpose
multiplied by the rest.
Why do we care about this?
Because basically the
idea of kernel methods--
in this very basic
form-- is what
if I replace this
inner product, which
is a way to measure similarity
between my functions,
with another similarity.
So instead of mapping
each x into a very high
dimensional vector and
then taking product--
which is itself, if you
want another way, as I said,
of measuring similarity
in your product,
distances between vectors--
what if I just define it,
instead of by an
explicit mapping,
by redefining the inner product.
So this k here is the
k similar to the one
we had in the previous--
in the very first slide.
And it's-- re-parametrize
the inner product.
Change the inner
product, and then I
want to use everything else.
So we need to question-- we
need to answer two question.
The first one is if I
give you now a procedure
that whenever you would
want to do x transpose
x does something else
called ax comma x prime.
How do you change
the computations?
This is going to be very easy.
But also what are you doing
from a modeling perspective?
So from the computational
point of view, it's very easy,
because you see
here you always had
that you have to build a
matrix whose entries were
xi transpose xj.
So it was always a
product of two vectors.
And what you do now is
that you do the same.
So you build the matrix
kn, which is not just xn,
xn transpose but is a new matrix
whose entries are just this.
This is just a generalization.
If I put the linear
kernel, I just get back
in what we had before.
If you put another kernel,
you just get something else.
So from a computational
point of view,
you're done for this
computation of c.
You have to do nothing else.
You just replace this matrix
with these general matrix.
And if you want
to now compute s--
so w you cannot compute
anymore, because you don't know
what's an x by itself.
But if you want to
compute f of x, you can,
because you've just to plug-in--
So you know how
to compute the c.
And you know how to compute this
quantity, because you have just
to put the kernel there.
So the magic here
is that you never
ever point x in isolation.
You always have a point x
multiplied by another point x.
And this allows you to
replace vectors by--
in some sense, this is
an implicit remapping
of the points by just
redefining the inner product.
So what you should
see for now is
just that the
computation that you've
done to compute f of x in
the linear case you can redo,
if you replace the inner
product with this new function.
Because A, you can compute c
by just using this new matrix
in place of this.
And B, you can replace f
of x, because all you need
is to replace this inner
product with this one
and put the right weights,
which you know how to compute.
From a modeling
perspective what you
can check is that, for
example, if you choose here
this polynomial kernel--
which is just x
transpose x prime plus 1
elevated to the d--
if you take, for
example, d equal 2,
this is equivalent to the
mapping I showed you before,
the one with explicit
monomials as entries.
This is just doing
it implicitly.
If you're in low-dimensional,
if you're low-dimensional,
if n is very big, and the
dimensions are very small,
the first way might be better.
But if n is much bigger,
this way would be better.
But also you can use stuff like
this, like a Gaussian kernel.
And in that case, you cannot
really write down explicitly
the explicit map,
because it turns out that
it's infinite-dimensional.
The vectors you would
need to write down,
to write down the explicit
variable version of--
embedding version of this
is infinite-dimensional.
So this is a--
if you use this, you get the
truly non-parametric model.
If you think of what is
the effect of using this,
it's quite clear if
you plug them here.
Because what you have
is that in one case
you have a superposition
of linear stuff,
a superposition of
polynomial stuff,
or a superposition of Gaussians.
So same game as before.
So same dataset we train.
I take kernel least squares--
which is what I
just showed you--
compute the c
inverting that matrix,
use the Gaussian kernel--
the last of the example--
and then compute f of x.
And then we just
want to plot it.
So this is the solution.
The algorithm depends
on two parameters.
What are they?
AUDIENCE: Lambda.
LORENZO ROSASCO: Lambda, the
regularization parameter,
the one that appeared
already in the linear case--
and then--
AUDIENCE: Whatever parameter
you've chosen [INAUDIBLE]..
LORENZO ROSASCO: Exactly.
Whatever parameters
there is in your kernel.
In this case, it's
the Gaussian, so it
will depend on this width.
Now suppose that
I take gamma big.
I don't know what big is.
I just do it by hand here,
so we see what happens.
If you take gamma--
sorry gamma, sigma big,
you start to get
something very simple.
And if I make it
a bit bigger, it
will probably start to look very
much like a linear solution.
If I make it small--
and again, I don't
know what small is,
so I'm just going to try.
I's very small.
You start to see
what's going on.
And if you go in
between, you really
start to see that you can
circle out individual examples.
So let's think a second
what we're doing here.
It is going to be again other
hand-waving explanation.
Look at this equation.
Let's read out what it says.
In the case of Gaussians,
it says, I take a Gaussian--
just a usual Gaussian--
I center it over a
training set point,
then by choosing the ci
I'm choosing whether it is
going to be a peak or a valley.
It can go up, or it can go down
in the two-dimensional case.
And by choosing
the width, I decide
how large it's going to be.
If I do f of x, then I sum up
all this stuff, which basically
means that I'm going to have
these peaks and these valleys
and I connect them in some way.
Now you remember before
that I pointed out
within the
two-dimensional case what
we draw is not f of x,
but f of x equal to zero.
So what you should really think
is that f of x in this case
is no longer an upper plane,
but it's this surface.
It goes up, and it goes down.
And it goes up,
and it goes down.
So in the blue part, it goes
up, and in the orange part,
it goes down into valley.
So what you do is
that right now you're
taking all these
small Gaussians,
and you put them in around
blue and orange point,
and then you
connect their peaks.
And by making them
small, you allow
them to create a very
complicated surface.
So what did we put before?
So they're small.
They're getting smaller,
and smaller, and smaller.
And they go out,
and you see the--
there is a point here,
so they circle it out
here by putting basically
Gaussian right there
for that individual point.
Imagine what happens
if my points--
I have two points here
and two points here--
and now I put a huge
Gaussian around each point.
Basically, the peaks are almost
going to touch each other.
So what you're
imagine is that you
get something, where basically
the decision boundary has
to look like a line,
because you get
something which is so smooth.
It doesn't go up and
down all the time.
It's going to be--
And that's what we
saw before, right?
And again, I don't
remember what I put here.
So this is starting
to look good.
So you really see that somewhat
something nice happens.
Maybe if I put-- five is
what we put before maybe.
So basically what
you're basically doing
is that you're computing
the center of mass
of one class in the
sense of the Gaussians.
So you're doing a
Gaussian mixture
on one side, a Gaussian
mixture on the other side,
you're basically computing
the center of masses,
and then you just
find the line that
separates the center of masses.
That's what you're
doing here, and you just
find this one big line here.
So again, so we're
not playing around
with the number of points.
We're not play
around with lambda.
But because this is basically
what we already saw before.
All I want to show you right
now is the effect of the kernel.
And here I'm using the Gaussian
kernel, but-- let's see--
but you can also use
the linear kernel.
This is the linear kernel.
This is using the
linear least squares.
If you now use the
Gaussian kernel,
you give yourself the
extra possibility.
Essentially, what you
see is that if you
put the Gaussian which is
very big, in some sense
you get back the linear kernel.
But if you put the Gaussian
which is very small,
you allow yourself to
this extra complexity.
And so that's what we gain
with this little trick
that we did of replacing
the inner product
with this new kernel.
We went from the simple
linear estimators
to something, which is--
It's the same
thing-- if you want--
that we did by
building explicitly
these monomials of higher
power, but here you're
doing it implicitly.
And it turns out
that it's actually--
there is no explicit
version that you can--
You can do it mathematically,
but the feature representation,
the variable representation
of this kernel
would be an infinitely
long vector.
The space of function
that is built
as a combination of Gaussians
is not finite-dimensional.
For polynomials, you can check
that the space of function,
it basically is a
polynomial in d.
If I ask you how
big is the function
space that you can build using
this-- well, this is easy.
It's just d-dimensional.
With this, well, this is
a bit more complicated,
but you can compute.
For this, it's not easy to
compute, because it's infinite.
So it in some sense is
a non-parametric model.
What does it mean?
Of course, you still
have a finite number
of parameters in practice.
And that's the good news.
But there is no fixed number
of parameters a priori.
If I give you a hundred points,
you get a hundred parameters.
If I give you 2 million points,
you get 2 million parameters.
If I give you 5 million points,
you get 5 million parameters.
But you never hit a
boundary of complexity,
because these are in some sense
as an infinite-dimensional
parameter space.
So of course, I
see that here there
are some of the part that I'm
explaining are complicated,
especially if this is the
first time you see them.
But the take-home message
should be essentially
from least squares,
I can understand
what's going on from a
numerical point of view
and bridge numerics
and statistics.
Then by just simple
linear algebra,
I can understand
the complexity--
how I can get
complexly-- which is
linear in the
number of dimension
or the number of points.
And then by following up,
I can do a a little magic
and go from the linear model
to something non-linear.
The deep reason why this is
possible are complicated.
But as a take-home
message, A, the computation
you can check easy.
It remained the same.
B, you can check that
what you're doing is now
allowing yourself to take
a more complicated model,
it's combination of
the kernel functions.
And then even just by playing
with these simple demos,
you can understand a
bit what is the effect.
And that's what you
intuitively would expect.
So I hope that it would
get you close enough
to have some awareness,
when you use this.
And of course, you can put--
when you abstract from the
specificity of this algorithm,
you build an algorithm with
one or two parameters--
lambda and sigma.
And so as soon as you ask
me how you choose those,
well, we go back to the
first part of the lecture--
bias-variance, tradeoffs,
cross-validation,
and so on and so forth.
So you just have to
put them together.
There is a lot of stuff
I've not talked about.
And it's a step away
from what we discussed,
so you've just seen the
take-home message part,
but we could talk
about reproducing
kernel hybrid spaces,
the functional analysis
behind everything I said.
We can talk about Gaussian
processes, which is basically
the probabilistic version of
what I just showed you now.
Then we can all see the
connection with a bunch of math
like integral
equations and PDEs.
There is a whole connection
with the sampling
theory a la Shannon,
inverse problems and so on.
And there is a
bunch of extension,
which are almost for free.
You change the loss function.
You can make the logistic,
and you take kernel
logistic regression.
You can take SVM, and
you get kernel SVM.
Then you can also take more
complicated output spaces.
And you can do multiclass,
multivariate regression.
You can do regression.
You can do multilabel,
and you can
do a bunch of different things.
And these are
really a step away.
These are minor
modification of the code.
And you can do a bunch of stuff.
So the good thing of this
is that with really, really,
really minor effort,
you can actually
solve a bunch of problem.
I'm not saying that it's going
to be the best algorithm ever,
but definitely it
gets you quite far.
So again we spent quite
a bit of time thinking
about bias-variance and
what it means and used
least squares and just
basically warming up
a bit with this setting.
And then in the last hour or
so, we discussed least squares,
because it allows to just think
in terms of linear algebra,
which is something that--
one way or another--
you've seen in your life.
And then from there, you can
go from linear to non-linear.
And that's a bit of magic,
but a couple of parts--
which are how you use
it both numerically
and just from a
practical perspective
to go from complex models to
simple models and vice versa--
should be-- is the part that
I hope you keep in your mind.
For now, our concern has just
been to make predictions.
If you hear
classification, you want
to have good clarification.
If you hear regression, you
want to do good regression.
But you didn't talk about-- we
didn't talk about understanding
how did you do good regression?
So a typical example is
the example in biology.
This is, perhaps, a bit old.
This is micro-arrays.
But the idea is the datasets
you have is a bunch of patients.
For each patient, you
have measurements,
and the measurements correspond
to some gene expression
level or some other
biological process.
The patients are divided in
two groups, say, disease type
A and disease type B. And
based on the good prediction
of whether a patient
is disease type A or B,
you can change the way you cure
it or you address the disease.
So of course, you want to
have a good prediction.
You want to be able-- when
a new patient arrive--
to say whether it's going
to-- this is type A or type B.
But oftentimes,
what you want to do
is that you want to use
this not as the final tool,
because unless deep
learning can solve this,
you might go back and study a
bit more the biological process
to understand a bit more.
So you use this as
more statistical tools
like measurements, like the
way you can use a microscope
or something to look into
your data and get information.
And in that sense
sometimes, it's
interesting to--
instead of just saying
is this patient going to be
more likely to be disease type
A or B, it's to
go in and say, ah,
but when you make
the prediction, what
are the process that
matters for this prediction?
Is this gene number 33 or 34,
so that I can go in and say,
oh, these genes make sense,
because they're in fact related
to these other processes,
which are known to be related,
involved in this disease.
And doing that, you use
just as a little tool,
then you use other
ones to get a picture.
And then you put them together.
And then it's mostly on the
doctor, or the clinician,
or the biostatistician to try
to develop better understanding.
But you do use these as
tools to understand and look
into the data.
And in that perspective,
the word interpretability
plays a big role.
And here by
interpretability I mean
I not only want to
make predictions,
but I want to know how I make
predictions and tell you, come
afterwards with an
explanation of how
I picked the information that
were contained in my data.
So so far it's hard to see how
to do it with the tools we had.
So this is basically the
field of variable selection.
And in this basic
form, the setting
where we do understand
what's going on
is the setting of linear models.
So in this setting
basically, I just
rewrite what we've seen before.
You have x is a vector, and you
can think of it, for example,
as a patient.
And xj are measurements
that you have
done describing this patient.
When you do a linear
model, you basically
have that by putting a
weight on each variables,
you're putting a weight
on each measurement.
If a measurement
doesn't matter, you
think you might put here a zero.
And it will disappear
from the sum.
If the measurement
matters a lot,
then here you might
get a big weight.
So one way to try to get the
feeling of which measurements
are important and which
are not and to try
to estimate and model, a linear
model, where you get the w,
but ideally we would like to
get the w, which has many zeros.
You don't want to fumble with
what's small and what's not.
So if you do least squares
the way I showed you before,
you would get a w.
Then you would get--
most of them you can check
that it will not be zero.
In fact, none of them
will be zero in general.
And so now you have to decide
what's small and what's big,
and that might not be easy.
Oops, what happened here?
So funny enough, this is
the name I found on how--
I don't remember the
name of the book.
It's the name that
was used to describe
the process of variable
selection, which
is a much harder
problem, because you
don't want to make predictions.
But you want to
go back and check
how you make the prediction.
And so it's very easy to start
to get overfitting and start
to try to squeeze the data
until you get some information.
So it's good to have
a procedure that
will give you somewhat a
clean procedure to extract
the important variables.
Again, you can think of
this as a-- basically,
I want to build an
f, but I also want
to come up with a list or even
better weights that tell me
which variables are important.
And often this will
be just a list,
which is much smaller than
d, so that I can go back
and say, oh, measurement 33,
34, and 50-- what are they?
I could go in and look at it.
Notice that there is also
a computational reason why
this would be interesting.
Because of course,
if d here is 50,000--
and what I see is
that, in fact, I
can throw away most of these
measurements and just keep 10--
then it means that
I can hopefully
reduce the complexity
of my computation,
but also the storage of
the data, for example.
If I have to send you
the datasets after I've
done this thing,
I've just to send you
this teeny tiny matrix.
So interpretability
is one reason,
but the computational
aspect could be another one.
Another reason that I don't
want to talk too much is also--
remember that we
had this idea, where
we said we could document
the complexity of a model
by inventing
features, and he said
do I always have to pay
the price of making it big?
Well, I basically--
if you what--
I was pointing at--
I said, no, not always, because
I was thinking of kernels.
These, if you want give
you another way potentially
to go around in which what
you do is that, first of all,
you explode the
number of features.
You take many, many,
many, many, and then
you use this as a
preliminary step
to shrink them down to a
more reasonable number.
Because it's quite
likely that among
these many, many
measurements, some of them
would just be very
correlated, or uninteresting,
or so on and so forth.
So this dimensionality
reduction or
computational or interpretable
model perspective
is what stands behind the desire
to do something like this.
So let's say one more
thing and then we'll stop.
So suppose that you have an
infinite computational power.
So the computation
are not your concern,
and you want to
solve this problem.
How will you do it?
Suppose that you have the
code for least squares.
And you can run it as
many times as you want.
How would you go and
try to estimate which
variables are more important?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
possibility of computations.
LORENZO ROSASCO:
That's one possibility.
What you do is that you have--
you start and look at
all single variables.
And you solve least squares
for all single variables.
Then you take all
couples of variables.
Then you get all
triplets of variables.
And then you find
which one is best.
From a statistical
point of view there
is absolutely nothing
wrong with this,
because you're
trying everything.
And at some point, you
find what's the best.
The problem is that
it's combinatorial.
And you see that when you're
in dimension a few more then--
very few, it's huge.
So it's exponential.
So it turns out that
doing what you just
told me to do, which is what
I asked you to tell me to do,
which is this brute
force approach
is equivalent to do
something like this is again
a regularization approach.
Here I put what is
called the zero norm.
The zero norm is
actually not a norm.
And it is just functional.
It's a thing that does
the following thing.
If I give you a vector,
you've to return
the number of components
different from zero, only that.
So you go inside and
look at each entry,
and you tell if they
are different from zero.
This is absolutely not convex.
And so this is the reason why
this problem is equivalent--
it becomes a computation
not feasible.
So perhaps, we can stop here.
And what I want to show
you next is essentially--
if you have this--
and you know that in some sense,
this is what you would like
to do, if you could
do it computationally,
but you cannot--
so how can you find
approximate version of this
that you can
compute in practice?
And we're going to discuss
two ways of doing it.
One is greedy methods and
one is convex relaxations.